this weekend the start Finish Line at
the South Point 400 is going to look a
little different and it's all in honor
of breast cancer awareness now earlier
in the week I was at Las Vegas Motor
Speedway the sponsors of this next
segment for the story behind this
special cause
all right Chris paint the line pink what
a special day tell us more about this
event well as soon as we found out that
our NASCAR weekend was going to be in
October we knew we wanted to do
something in association with the
American Cancer Society and with breast
cancer awareness and we had some very
creative employees who came to me a few
months ago and they said well now that
we're in October we've got to do
something special we got to do something
in pink and a little did I know it was
going to be the start Finish Line but
when they came up with that idea and we
got NASCAR's approval I thought what a
great statement we can make to race fans
and to people who have been affected by
breast cancer and hardly anybody has who
is out here today we had Ryan brownie
from the South Point Hotel Casino and
Spa in rounding Ryan is the general
manager of the south point so Ryan was
here helping us paint as well as Noah
Gregson who competes both in the Xfinity
series he's from Las Vegas and this
weekend he's going to race for in the
cup series for his first time in Las
Vegas oh it's great to be here
supporting the breast cancer survival
drivers and you know patients everybody
who's been affected through breast
cancer to be able to paint the star
Finish Line pink when you cross the
finish line this weekend will be this be
the first ever finish line that you
cross that you painted yeah yeah they
might have to touch up my lines I was
always pretty good at coloring in the
lines but I'm not too good at painting
someone's watching right now and may be
struggling right now with breast cancer
and stuff what kind of words of
encouragement do we have for that for
that person right now you know what the
initial diagnosis really sucks and the
whole process is a pain but at the end
you feel so good that you know it's done
and you're over it and you know for me
it was 10 years ago it was and I'm 10
years cancer free wow right and so
foreign
your 10 years cancer free got an
official flyover well I'm here with Gail
who flew in from Florida for this
special day and breast cancer has had a
big impact on your family can you tell
us more we have
four first cousins right now
who are survivors
my mom was a victim her sister was a
Survivor this is something that's near
and dear to us I I can't begin to tell
people though
the one three word you never want to
hear is you have cancer
but through these organizations we're
able to say there's still hope encourage
early examinations
Brothers in the house that prostrate
cancer is one that you must must take
seriously it's not just breast cancer
this is something that affects any and
everyone Childhood Cancer is something
that'll bring tears to your eyes but
when you see a child that's survived
bald headed yesterday and having flowing
hair tomorrow that's what you live for